hablamos ahora economía aquí en directo
américa france24 me acompañan la
estudian y elaboran don dani bienvenida
fue la mañana de viernes este fin de
semana es electoral aquí en colombia ni
que país deja el presidente saliente
iván duque hola raúl muy buenos días un
feliz viernes pues este domingo ya
sabemos es la primera vuelta
presidencial y el mandatario saliente de
colombia deja un país que trata de
recuperarse de los efectos de la
pandemia pero también con enormes retos
que vienen de mucho antes de la crisis
sanitaria como por ejemplo la alta
pobreza y la desigualdad veamos primero
el crecimiento económico raúl si le
pareció mire este es un país que ha
mantenido un aumento sostenido del
producto interno bruto en las últimas
dos décadas entre el 1% y el 7%
dependiendo del año en su pico más
reciente pueden 69 por ciento en 2011
casi dos años después de la llegada de
iván duque la tendencia se vio
interrumpida por la pandemia y el pip se
desplomó un 6 8% para recuperarse en 10
6% en 2 danny y es que en colombia 4 de
cada 10 habitantes viven en la pobreza
un tema de mucho antes raúl debido al
impacto de la pandemia sin embargo en
colombia cientos de miles de personas
fueron arrastradas a la pobreza y hoy la
cifra está a punto de tocar los 20
millones mientras que aquellos que no
pueden cubrir sus necesidades de
alimentación básicas es decir quienes
viven en la pobreza extrema son 61
millones de personas el gobierno eduque
inicio cuando el país tenía una pobreza
general del 34 7% y del 82 % en
condiciones extremas vemos como ha
fluctuado a lo largo de estos años fue
subiendo y en pandemias se disparó al 42
5 por ciento y la tasa de pobreza
extrema fue la que más sufrió porque se
duplicó hasta el 15,1 por ciento ahora
veamos 2021 la situación ha mejorado se
estima que la crisis sin embargo borró
una década de avance todavía cuatro de
cada diez son pobres como usted lo
mencionaba es decir subsisten con menos
de 89 dólares al mes y uno de cada dos y
una de cada diez son pobres extremos
para sumarle a todo esto daniela es uno
de los países más desiguales claro
porque la pobreza es un tema pero la
pobre la desigualdad es uno peor quizá y
es la distribución de la riqueza el
banco mundial cree que colombia ocupa el
segundo lugar el lugar en américa latina
después de brasil y que en la ocde que
es también conocido como el club de
países ricos es el más desigual y le voy
a dar un ejemplo el 10% de la población
más rica en colombia tiene 11 veces más
ganancias o más riqueza que el 10 por
ciento de la población más pobre y
lamentablemente seguimos hablando de más
problemas porque el problema más
apremiante actual es la inflación no
como en todo el mundo claro como en todo
el mundo raúl en este país los más de 51
millones de habitantes están sufriendo o
estamos sufriendo también nosotros las
consecuencias indirectas de la guerra en
ucrania y es que los precios de la
canasta familiar en abril
de 92 por ciento más altos que en el
mismo mes de 2002 y 1 es 11 de sus
niveles más altos en dos décadas
colombia siempre ha mantenido una
inflación aproximada del 3% en promedio
el gobierno justifica los números
negativos diciendo que se trata de un
fenómeno inflacionario mundial por
ejemplo colombia tiene una gran
dependencia de los fertilizantes rusos
ahora miramos el desempleo que es hoy
del 12,1 por ciento se ha venido
disparando después de haber bajado a un
dígito en años anteriores significa que
hay 3 millones de desempleados
escuchamos el siguiente análisis el
principal desafío a mi juicio tiene que
ver con la economía colombia está en
este momento viviendo un gran auge
económico una economía recalentada a
todas luces creciendo al doble de lo que
ha venido creciendo en los últimos 30
años y eso no aguanta no aguanta en el
sentido de que produce inflación de
precios al consumidor inflación de
precios al productor produce desbalances
y hay que ver como ese próximo gobierno
va a lograr cerrar esos balances y
estabilizar la economía para que no
venga una recesión
danielle y como están los indicadores
económicos pero caras contentas hoy en
las bolsas de las acciones asiáticas
subieron este viernes a medida que los
inversionistas aplaudieron un sólido
conjunto de ganancias de firmas
minoristas como alibaba y baidu en
europa se respira el mismo optimismo sus
principales índices van en camino a
cerrar la semana en positivo y para
finalizar que nos trae como cifra el día
tu canción favorita de justin timberlake
javier river sin duda es también el
amigo mi bears que mide 100 millones de
dólares las cifras de hoy en esta en
este valor justin timberlake vendió a
los derechos de sus canciones a un grupo
que se llama hip noches son management y
después este catálogo musical incluye
éxitos como cae mier river su favorito
me bears el mío una estrella más del que
saca provecho de su trabajo en el
candente mercado de las plataformas de
streaming ahora si se preguntara qué
significa eso esta empresa lo que hace
es comprar catálogos de canciones de
artistas y obtener ingresos cuando la
música se transmite en línea o se usa en
películas o también en publicidad
ya me dieron ganas a escuchar esta
canción a presentar yo en el programa la
pongo para relajarme un poco dani
muchísimas gracias nos vemos o más
adelante con más economía en nuestra
segunda ahora nos vamos directo a
venezuela